we begin this half hour with a cruise to
nowhere it might sound strange but in
our era of covid it's turned into a
popular escape option for tens of
thousands of people in asia since the
pandemic began it turns out hong kong
has the world's longest mandatory hotel
quarantine at up to three weeks and
that's kept people from leaving in the
first place as remy and ocenzio found
out these new staycation cruises that
loop out to sea are designed to get
around all of those restrictions
flying out of hong kong's waters the
genting dream cruise ship offers a
breath of fresh air on the south china
sea for stir crazy city dwellers from
water slides with short lines since ship
capacity is restricted to 50 percent
to stage shows with acrobats spinning
and flying while masked audiences watch
socially distanced
this is a coveted free bubble floating
on the high seas
kent zhu president of genting cruises
tells me all passengers above 12 and
every crew member must be fully
vaccinated at least two weeks before
sailing certainly full vaccination
for passengers is a good thing a
disruption of a cruise is also very
troublesome for everybody
that's also why two days before sailing
every passenger has to do a rapid covet
test on land
my negative result texted to me in less
than 24 hours
on check-in every passenger has to show
proof of health my vaccination card from
new york
this
checklist of places that i've been or
not
then we set sail with our 600 other
fellow escapees hong kong's lights
melting into the night but coven
measures don't stop there every
passenger has to wear this contact
tracing device called tracy it's
basically to track
how close we are at any given
time oh there it is a light blinks red
if two people are less than five feet
away anyone who has a fever for example
they will go immediately go to our
medical center 44 rooms to isolate
anyone of interest with negative
pressure systems to suck air out and a
rapid covered testing room
back up on the top deck can't drew
counts his blessings has there ever been
a positive kobe case
taught you what never
that perfect track record since june
30th means peace of mind for all
including me time for some fun
zipping down water slides and splashing
out at the end
dancing with the crew during an
oktoberfest party
brushing up on my bowling and losing to
the president with a contact high five
our crews coming back after one day and
two nights ending a bit too soon i
definitely do that again a quick
refreshing escape safe from kovitz
showing that even if you can't go
somewhere you can still go nowhere for
cbs saturday morning i'm raymie
innocencio in hong kong